walk him to this video playing the Wayne
do wine I probably mispronounced it
anyway um this is my 11th game against
this guy and it's about fifty percent so
let's see you play the Chernenko sloth
let's see what is coming up with c5 yeah
apple in 97 again at least i played this
when I was regularly employing the
Chevin ankle yeah that's a move that's a
move not a very common with but it is
played so let's consider I cannot go g6
for obvious reasons if I take it maybe I
should just take it out it's a bit
accommodating but I cannot spend an hour
to fire find the right or that the
completely right reply this is at least
a playable a play will set up okay and
so should i do f6 trying to quickly get
in e5 hmm that's tempting actually but
I'm not sure not sure
that's a more roll always amazed how
quickly people play those this very very
committal moves I'm not saying that it
is bad but it's a kind of no point of no
return move ok so if form yeah probably
94 I need f65 here I get in Bishop e62 d
hive for a counterclaim
now Bishop c4 maybe now could be an
idiom okay
the other thing is I'm not getting mated
yet not with the bishop on g7 and if I'm
not mate it I'm not sure what what the
what the point is of all this okay let's
see so f 66 just f6 why not
okay night will probably go to see form
might be sick smell that's not not
really am so terrifying or f5 here now
f5 not not doing much Quincy 827 does
not be six okay I need to play
okay I can also i can just take g fire
takes critics but this Bishop c4 yeah
that's that's not ideal yeah but still I
can do that maybe maybe go for the
exchange like if it's an interesting way
to play as much so not taking
immediately interesting now may be the
right decision I mean I can take here
queen bee three the c6 I can maybe check
here and play Queen d7 attacking also
g-form
hm queen d7 looks like strong move I'm
not quite sure what I should do against
it may be Queen D aid trying to get this
counter play with Queen a five if he
takes on g4 this is some counter play
Piquet probably just trade Queens and
play em play age five check okay h5 next
move on what is the idea maybe yeah
we'll get seven I cannot play okay check
so let's see let's see how awful that
really is probably it is all for me but
still I'd like to to see what is doing
now and the Queen d3 coming
I think he had much easier ways to play
maybe this is winning as well but it
does not feel very necessary it takes on
g6 I have at least this perpetual on d3
maybe more not sure but I'm okay with
the perpetual at the moment
not sure what you should do know it's
really not easy takes on Friday when I
we know those phones i mean i'm really
not sure what you should do maybe he's
in trouble I don't know this is a big
threat of Queen d3
now this was skype not not and Chet from
the opponent yeah it just played it all
very very quickly and I don't know if
you push all the pawns your own king is
exposed as well so it's not that easy
that you can play everything instantly
I don't see move really maybe there is
some kind of draw but check check check
okay let's think about this here should
be for I am this is threatening Bishop
b2 and Bishop e3 Bishop e3 mate and
Bishop b2 when I the Queen that's quite
quite problematic
he's got no check nothing he just played
it too quickly i was totally busted
white resides yeah around here I'm
really busted without any doubt k this
up late and takes takes check do ya here
just between g4 probably I thought this
was relatively easy well again I got
some plain computer wants to take here
to have check before maybe this is the
easiest plus 5 m according to the
country i am totally busted quite quite
clearly and it seems that when we were
here I should do something else here
maybe Quincy seven or something
intending rock d aid I don't know I'm
under some pressure yeah but this this
is really lost again check but the funny
thing is here after Queen a fight Black
is winning already funny here does a
draw okay h take g6 is drawing but she
didn't play Jackie I wasn't sure but
yeah of course i can give this all this
chicks the question is can i win in some
behave but try at least age 6 okay this
i can still try and now queen e7
intending look aged 6 is securing the
draw of course i can always give those
checks but i also don't have more than
that this sound check however jack is
losing just like it happened in the game
yeah it was a bit too confident and
played played it too quickly i was
totally lost alright thanks for watching